Kyle this is Kyle boys gang gang
this is Kyle from Nova Scotia lucky Oh
Brendan you are usually present as well
Danah mobis fallen on hard times
whoa whoa whoa what's the king of sleaze
it's at the everything weights it
strongman competitions oh wow oh that's
a lot of weight B that's like seven
that's probably eight what two hundred
pounds I don't know I just wish
somebody'd get on a diet make more music
that's earned bro you did throw a little
shade at you I think I like the ones
where the guys yeah you look like a
strong guy and I think it's good if
something falls on somebody you're there
if you can help you know I think being
real strong is hard to do I think that
uh if you I think one thing is that I
like to contest where the guys running
on the log and he's hitting the truth
chopping the tree down you know those
ones and then they're doing the thing
where they're climbing up the tree every
single warrior on ESPN no no no no oh
yeah warrior but like in Portland yeah
[Music]
so I love those contests man but the
strong ones are crazy when you see the
guy who like throws those like there's
beer keg things over the fence or
whatever
yeah like Magnus and those guys I like
the real strongman thing but unless you
want them top dogs just lifting weight
saying you're strong man contest yeah
you know I'm saying but it's a good
sport that it's still you know it's a
good sport that um yeah it kind of it's
almost very Greek or like you know
almost old-school times where it's like
you also have no other choices you know
I'm saying like you don't become a big
fat strong man because you're good at
basketball
kill me well it's amazing how some of
these guys you think would be good like
offensive lineman
good defensive linemen now too athletic
to be one of those guys only yeah yeah
they could never do it
oh you mean being one of them guys with
b2f yeah wait to athlete so to on anyway
it's it's weird because there's because
they're two on ethics yeah there you go
yeah well you don't need to do that yeah
here's the thing though with the
strongman guys not this guy well kind of
it's called fit fat right because they
lift so much weights they so much food
so they're fat but they're really strong
oh yeah it's kind of it's it's not
healthy you know I'm saying yeah you got
bratwurst four veins and [ __ ] but it's
beautiful man you know I love seeing a
big big strong guy carrying something
you know dude and the guy the guy also
they do the things were they what else
do they do they got to pull that semi
truck and that's a nice imagine for your
semi truck breaks down and you just got
a some skinny guy like me buy it you're
[ __ ] you got this guy with you this
dude pull it down interstate deadlift a
Prius
have you seen you know get from Game of
Thrones I don't want season you're on
but you see the mountain man he's the
strongest guy in the world
yeah I heard about that shoot is he that
strong now strongest in the world
he knows he's also 400 pounds so I hope
you're [ __ ] strong you know I'm
saying good that's a good point dude I'm
174 pounds dude so I'm not that strong
but you can probably lift 170 pounds
yeah dude I dude 600 pounds bragging
that he benches 600 pounds alright cool
man
I'll king it cuz I actually dig those
strongman contests and I watch the doc -
yeah man the weights get heavy dude I
commend you for still lifting in my room
when I was young and weights wasn't
where were not that heavy now they get
heavier as I get older I get heavy yeah
so if you can be strong man keep being
strong what else did he ask about just
King under staying here yeah I would say
King at man but I think you guys could
should do I would like to see new
contest within that contest like it's
always throwing the keg over the the
whole semi yeah there's everything let's
do some real rocks yeah carry ya
carrying that's carrying people yeah
you're fat chicks up there and trying to
[ __ ] lift them you know they are
super fat chicks you notice you think oh
yeah dude viki's hmm Mountain has a tiny
like twinkle little girl but the rest of
them sticky but dude it's are we into
that big amount animals probably try to
come getting your shade at night like
it's during the day like I bet it's like
imagine two cows walk up two units take
a nap next to you dude like that big
your experience and a lot of things the
rest of us aren't experienced bigger
things too you know well dude I'm sure
there's probably somebody trust a boat
you know probably you know some
nightingale's try to build a little nest
on your shoulder like imagine dealing
with that all day while you're trying to
do the computer a grizzly bear trying to
snuggle with these guys go through again
I king it imagine moss growing on the
north side of your [ __ ] stuff dude
yeah again that's why King it they're
good and they're sweaty all the time
yeah measure if somebody climbs up in
the middle the night to get to get our
honey out of like uh somebody's built a
sack by your ear and like you know sure
the things these people go through not
here that's why Kingdom in how King it
then this says this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
weird where'd we get this China
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]